هجوم اسرائيليه شله مطار دمشق ويستهدف
مواقع ميليشيا حزب الله جنوب العاصمه
السوريه
مسيرات الروسيه تستهد
وشرقيه اوكرانيا والجيش الاوكرانيه ردوا
بقصف مناطق في بالجروب الروسيه
والمانيا بجمع معلومات عن المعارضين على
اراضيهم
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طبتها اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه
النشره الاخباريه من العربيه
لحقوق الانسان بان الطائرات الاسرائيليه
على مواقع حزب الله اللبنانيه والحرس
الثوري الايراني في محيط وجنوب العاصمه
دمشق وابقى ما فائده المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان
متتاليه دوت في الاماكن المستهدفه وان
الصواريخ وصلت لاهدافها وادت الى مقتل
اربعه اشخاص محدثه اضرار ماديه كبيره
وتتواجد في المنطقه المستهدفه مستودعات
للسلاح والذخيره تابع لحزب الله وللحرس
الثوري كما افاد الجيش النظام السوري
بخروج مطار دمشق الدولي عن الخدمه بسبب
الضربات الاسرائيليه ومقتنع عنصرين من قوه
بالنسبه للخسائر البشريه اربعه قتلوا
بينهم على الاقل اسنان من الجنسيه السوريه
ايييه طبعا لان لم اذا ما كانوا ضمن
القوات العسكريه النظاميه ام سوريين
يعملون مع حزب الله اللبناني وايران مثل
الست الذين قتلوا قبل ايام في جنوب دمشق
لكن نعود الى الان الى هذا القصف الجديد
الاول خلال هذا العام يستهدف المطار داخل
المطار خارج المصارعه عن الخدمه واستهدف
ايضا مبنى في محيط المطار استاذه المستودع
في محيط المطار اي هناك ثلاث ستات في تلك
المنطقه المستودع واقع ما بين السيده زينب
والمطار همم على ما يبدو ان الهدف الرئيسي
كان مطار دمشق الدولي فشلت الدفاعات
الجويه باسقاط الصواريخ الاسرائيليه
تفاصيل جديده تم الكشف عنها حول ما بحثه
وزراء دفاع تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو
الاسبوع الماضي وفي التفاصيل اكدت دمشق
قال انقره وافقت على الانسحاب من الاراضي
السوريه
بنظره السوري سؤال باتت اجابته تقترب اكثر
من اي وقت ففي مسار خريطه الاتصال بين
انقره ودمشق يبدو ان القطارات تطبيع ماضا
في سكته وهي خريطه طريق ترتكز على عده
محطات
الاسبوع الماضي شهيد لقاءا غير مسبوق منذ
11 عاما يجسد خطوات مهمه في التقارب
التركي السوري فبعد لقاء وزراء دفاع تركيا
وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو بمشاركه قاده
اجهزه الاستخبارات كشف وزير الخارجيه
التركي عن اجتماعا مع نظيره السوري
والروسي منتصف يناير الحالي مشيرا الى انه
قد يعقد في بلد اخر
تقارب متسارع وتفاصيل تتكشف عن اللقاء
الثلاثي الاخير في تركيا وافقت على
الانسحاب الكامل من الاراضي في الشمال
السوري واكدت على احترامها وحده وسلامه
الاراضي السوريه في الاجتماع ايضا عن قرا
اكدت انها لم تعد ترحب باللاجئين السوريين
فعودتهم كانت على راس الملفات اجتماع
موسكو بحث ايضا وفق مسؤول تركي لرويترز
امن الحدود والعمل المشترك بين انقره
ودمشق لمواجهه ومكافحه المواصفات
بالارهاب الذي تمثله قصد وداعش وباقي
التنظيمات صحيفه الوطن السوريه المقربه من
النظام اكدت نقلا عن مسؤولين سوريين ان
الاطراف اتفقت على اعتبار حزب العمال
الكردستاني مليشيا عميله للولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وتشكيل خطرا على سوريا وتركيا
تفاهمات القت بظلالها على شمال سوريا حيث
رفض المسؤولون الاكراد المحليون مخرجات
لقاء موسكو الثلاثي وعوده النظام ممددين
بما اعتبره منحى الشرعيه للنظام
افاده عمده العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيب بان
عده انفجارات هزه المدينه فجر اليوم وان
اجهزه الطوارئ تتعامل مع الاضرار فيما
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني تدميره سعد مسيرات
من طراز شاهد فيها هجمات
وكان حاكم منطقه كيف اعلن حال التاهب
الجويه في معظم مناطق اوكرانيا للتحذير من
غارات جويه الروسيه ومن تهديد بطائرات
مسيره ايرانيه الصنع من نوع شاهد قد
تستهدف مدينتكيف والجزء الشرقي من
اوكرانيا في الوقت التي انطلقت صافرات
الانذار في تلك المناطق تحسبا من غاراتا
محتمله
افاد المتحدث باسم القوات المسلحه الروسيه
باستهداف المرافق عسكري اوكرانيه تستعمله
في تطوير تستعمله في تطوير وتصنيع وتخزين
الطائرات المسيره الهجوميه مؤكدا بان
القصف الروسي تسبب باحباط مخططات اخرىنيه
لاستهداف الاراضي الروسيه على حد قوله
الروسيه ضربه جويه باسلحه عاليه الدقه على
مرافق صناعيه اوكرانيه تستعمل في تصنيع
وتطوير الطائرات مسيره الهجوميه والتي
تستخدم ضد روسيا كما قامت قوتنا باستهداف
مرافق تخزين الطائرات المسيره وتعطيل خطتك
كيف لتنفيذ الهجمات على روسيا
اعلن الرئيس الاوكرانيا فلود ميرسي لانسكي
ان قوات بلاده دمرت 45 طائره مسيره تابعه
لروسيا في اليوم الاول من العام الجديد
واضاف ان قوه الروسيه استهدفت العديد من
المناطق الاخرانيه بطائرات مسيره ذات
صناعه ايرانيه
للتيار
33 طائره مسيره من نوع شاهد والشكر
لقواتنا البريه التي اسقطت اثنتي عشر
طائره مسيره ايرانيه اخرى
افادى موقعه هيرانا الايرانيه ان محكمه
الثوربي بمدينه ساري شمال ايران اتهمت
المهدي محمد فرد وهو شاب يبلغ من العمر 18
عاما تم اعتقاله خلال الاحتجاجات في شهر
بالافساد في الارض وحكمت عليه بالاعدام
بمدينه سميره في محافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد
بعد مقتل عنصر من الحرس الثوري وقالت ان
القوات الامن هاجمت منزل احد ضحايا
الاحتجاجات في هذه المنطقه اعتقلت بعض
اقاربه ونقلته وكاله الانباء الايرانيه عن
نائب قائد الحرس الثوري في اصفهان قوله ان
احد عناصر الحرس الثوري قتل السبت برصاص
مسلحين خلال مواصفات
نشدت على استخبارات الالمانيه ذوي الاصول
الايرانيه المعارضين ان يتوخوا الحذر حال
رغبتهم بالسفر الى ايران واكدت
الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان على ذوي الاصول
الايرانيه المعارضين ان يتوقعوا عواقب
وخيمه وقال رئيس الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان
المشاركين في تظاهرات التضامن مع ايران
السابقه التقطت صورا ومقاطع فيديو لبعضهم
ونشروها على مواقع التواصل ما سهل على
الاجهزه الايرانيه تحديدا هويتهم
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه ان تغيير
رئيس البنك المركزي الايرانيه لا يعد
كافيا لحل الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تعاني
منها ايران وذلك يا عاقبه التضخم الذي
يرافق قيمه الريال الايراني منذ اكثر من
شهرين
تسلك العمله الايرانيه مسار انحراريا سبق
لليرتين السوريه واللبنانيه عند خالتها في
نفقه
ورغم اقاله رئيس البنك المركزي الايراني
صالح عيادي وتعيين محمد رضا فرزين بدلا
منه لا يبدو كبح تدهور العمله الايرانيه
في متناول السلطات الايرانيه
في وقت فقد فيه التومان الايراني نحو ربع
قيمته في شهرين فقط ما جعل هذا التغيير لا
يعد حلا كافيا وفقا لخبراء اقتصاديين
صحيفه ارمان ميل الاصلاحيه الايرانيه ذكرت
انه من الخطا انتظار معجزه يقودها رئيس
البنك المركزي الجديد بالاضافه الى انه لا
جدوى من هذه التغييرات ما دامت السياسه
العامه للنظام الايراني غير قابله لتعديل
مسارها والعلاقات بين ايران ودول العالم
شبه منقطعه جراء العزله الدوليه والعقوبات
المفروضه على طهران بسبب قمعها الاحتجاجات
يضاف اليها التورط الايراني في تسليح
روسيا بالطائرات المسيره التي تستهدف
منشات المدنيه الاوكرانيه بينها البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه ما تسبب ايضا لايران
بخساره الموقف الاوروبي الوسطي وجنوحه
اكثر نحو الموقف الامريكي وبالتالي عقوبات
اوروبيه بعد الامريكيه التضخم ايضا مشكله
كبيره في ايران على ضوء الارقام القياسيه
التي يسجلها
تضخم يترافق مع انخفاض في قيمه التمان من
نحو
330,000 الى
430,000, مقابل الدولار الامريكي
في شق النوويه وفي ظل ضغوط للناس سياسيه
داخليه وازمه اقتصاديه طاحنه تبدي ايران
استعدادها لاحياء مفاوضات الاتفاق النوويه
في الوقت ذاته صرح مسؤول امريكي لموقع
جدتي ايران ان السياسيين الايرانيين قتلوا
اي فرصه لعوده سريعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بعقبه وتلاشيف راسي تحقيق اختراق يسلم
العام 2022 الايراني ودائعه للعام الجديد
في طيران
اوروبيه اساسها ضد المحتاجين
التي شكلت ريهانا كبيرا على الخروج من عنق
زجاجتي الازمه الاقتصاديه
حمل في هذا السياق مسؤوليه مراوحه
المفاوضات النوويه للسلطات الايرانيه وفق
موقع اجاده ايران مشيرا الى ان طهران قتلت
حدود العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بسبب رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه
عليها خلال العامين الماضيين لكن بالنسبه
الى المسؤولين الايرانيين فلديهم رؤيه
سياسيه مختلفه عبر عنها في اكثر من مناسبه
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الله الفرصه
هتقول لي اتخاذي الخطوات النهائيه لاحياء
الاتفاق النووي لكنها لن تبقى كذلك للابد
لكن خلف تعثر ريبيا عند تحقائق فرضتها
عوامل بعضها قديم واساسي وبعضها الاخر
مستجد في العوامل القديمه اصرار ايران على
غلق ملف التحقيق باثر اليورانيوم في عده
مواقع نوويه يقابله اصرار من الوكاله
الدوليه بمواصله التحقيق وانتظار اجوبه
واضحه من منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
في العناصر الجديده انزلاق ايران او
تورطها في تسليح روسيا بالمسيرات في حربها
على اوكرانيا ايضا برز موقف امريكي جديد
نقل الاولويه من مفاوضات فيينا الى
احتجاجات ايران واشنط ستركز جهودها على
امدادات الاسلحه الايرانيه الى روسيا وعلى
دعم المتظاهرين بدلا من التركيز على
المحادثات النوويه المعطله التي لا نعرفها
فائدتها
حاله عدم يقين سياسي تترافق مع تازم
الاقتصادي ضغط وتدفع الاحتجاجات
والاضرابات الى التحول الى مشهد دائم في
المدن الايرانيه طالب تبدا بشعارات الحريه
والانتفاضه على النظام وتمر بالتضخم
والوظائف والاجور كالملف النووي تبقى
معلقه بلا اجابات او معالجات مستدامه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
مع دخول العام الجديد رصدن لقرارات طالبان
المجهفه في حق المراه الافغانيه
حياكم الله اكد نائب رئيس مجلس اسياد
الانتقاليه السوداني محمد حمدان دقلوا ان
الحكومه حريصه على وضع حد لما وصفها
بتجاوزات والاحداث المؤسفه في محليه
بالليل بولايه جنوب دارفور
ضروره التصدي لمن وصفهم باصحاب الاجندات
من الناشطين الذين
والفتن وسط المجتمع ويسيرون النعرات
القبليه والعنصريه مشددا على ضروره نشر
ثقافه السلام والتعايش السلمي بين كافه
المجتمعات وطالب دجله بعدم التستر او
حمايه اي مجرم او منفرد
من جانب الاخر جدد رئيسه المجلس الاعلى
لنظارات البجا والعموديه المستقله محمد
الامين الترك خلال مخاطبته حجدا بولايه
كسلا رفضهم للاتفاق الايطالي واوضح طرق
للعربيه انهم يطالبون بمنبر منفصل لشرق
السودان او حق تقرير المصير خلال فتره
اقساها شهر من اليوم مضيفا ان لديه حكومه
جاهزه لشرق السودان
ان احنا رفضنا هذا الاتفاق الاطاري
والان نطالب بمنبر منفصل
لهذا المطلب
فنحن مع السودان ووحده السودان وقوه
السودان
اذا رفضتم حتما سنعود لهذا القصر
الله يبارك فيك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاعلام دهانات
موافقه معلومات قدمها جهاز الامن الوطني
العراقي تم الكشف عن اكبر شبكه لتهريبي
النفط الخام وعن الاليات والطرق التي تمت
بها عمليات التهريب والبيع للنفط المسروق
ومشتقاته ومن بين المتورطين بتهريب كميات
تقدر بنحو 75 مليون لتر شهريا من النفط
ضبط ضباط كبار في وزاره الداخليه العراقيه
لجنه التحقيق العراقيه بما وصف بفضيحه
سرقه ضباط للنفط الخام في محافظه البصره
تكشف عن اليات وطرق عمليات التهريب وبيع
النفط المسروق
قضيه النفط تورط فيها تسعه ضباط في وزاره
الداخليه تتراوح رتبهم بين لواء رائد
شاركوا شبكه واسعه لسرقه النفط الخام في
محافظه البصره الجنوبيه جهاز الامن
العراقي اطلع لجنه التحقيق على معلومات
استخباراتيه جزئيه بشان قضيه التهريب قالت
ان حلولا الليل كان شرطا لاتمام عمليات
السرقه وبشكل يومي والدوره المنوط بالضباط
يعتمد على حمايه المهربين اثناء احداثهم
ثغرات بالخطوط الناقله ثم مدي انابيب منها
الى اماكن تحميل النفط عبر شاحنات تقوم
بدورها بتهريبه الى اقليم كردستان الشمالي
ومنه الى سوريا ودول اخرى حيث يتم بيعه
يحصل ضباطوا بالمقابل على نحو
320,000$ حصيله ثغره انبوب واحد وتقدر
كميات المهربه يوميا من خمسه الى سبعه
صهاريج بسعه 50,000 لتر للخرق الواحد فيما
يقدر عدد الصهاريج المهربه من 40 الى 50
صهريجا بمعدل 75 مليون لتر شهريا اللافت
ان عمليات سرقه وبيع النفط لا تقتصر على
محافظه البصره بل ومنذ سنوات تتردد
معلومات في تقارير محليه عن عمليات سرقه
وتهريب للنفط ومشتقاته في معظم المحافظات
العراقيه التي يتوفر بها الذهب الاسود
استقبل الافغاني اول ايام السنه الميلاديه
الجديده بانفجار عبوه الناسفه قرب نقطه
تفتيش في محيط مطار كابول العسكري وفقا ما
اعلنته حركه طالبان وافد مراسل العربيه
نقل عن مصادر المستقله ان الانفجار اسفر
عن مقتل 14 شخص واصابه العشرات بجروح
يستهدف انفجار
العاصمه بالقرب من مطار كابول البوابه
الرئيسيه لمن يريد مغادره افغانستان
العامه من الممكن ان تقع في مدن متقدمه
والتي تخضع لاجراءات امنيه مشدده كامري
وجارتنا باكستان واوزباكستان وغيرها من
الدول
على امره
بعد كل تحول سياسي في البلاد ان يتحسن
الوضع الامني لكن اماله غالبا ما تتلاشى
مع كل هجوم جديد
سوف تستمر انما الايام قريبا
ترجح المعلومات الاوليه وحيثيات الانفجار
بمسؤوليه الداعش عن العمليه خصوصا ان
السلسله التفجيرات الاخيره تبناها التنظيم
الانفجار هذا استهدف منطقه حساسه وفي اول
يوم من العام الجديد لوجهها رساله واضحه
للسلطات في كابول بان العام الجديد سوف
يكون محذوفا بمثل هذه العمليات نادر
العربيه كابول
منذ وصول الطالبان الى السلطه في اغسطس
2021 وهي تقوم بفرض قرارات مجحفه في حق
المراه الافغانيه التي ظهرت في عده
مناسبات احتجاجها على ما طالها من ظلم من
قبل السلطه الحاكمه
كرتونائيه الماء والنار علاقه طالبان
بنساء افغانستان رغم ذلك تجدد بعثه الامم
المتحده مساعيها لفك القيود التي لم
تستهدف مهان النساء ومستقبل الفتيات فحسب
بل مصير الشعب الافغاني لقاء القائم
باعمال الممثل الخاص الامين العام للامم
المتحده بقياده طالبان حمل تحذيرا واضحا
من ان منع النساء من العمل وحرمان الفتيات
من التعليم
سيعيقان وصول المساعدات الى كل شرائح
المجتمع في افغانستان لكن لا يبدو ان
طالبان ستتراجع عن قراراتها وخصوصا ان
للحركه موقفا متجذرا وعادي للمراه فما
استيلاء الحركه على السلطه في اغسطس من
عام 2021 بدات تحركا منهجا لاقصاء المراه
الافغانيه وبدات معها تظاهرات واحتجاجات
ضد عمليه التهم
رفعت المراه الافغانيه بشكل مبكر مطالب
الرفضي وشعارات خبز عمل حريه
تظاهرات سارعت طالبان الى اخمادها اما
بالهراوات او خراطيم المياه
والاعتقالات واحيانا باطلاق النار ضغوط
وتظاهرات مقابل انقلاب طالبان على
الالتزامات وشروط المصالحه عوامل حاله دون
اي اعتراف دولي بها لكن الحركه لم تستجب
للضغوط واصدر اتباعا 16 قرارا ضد حقوق
النساء وككل قرار تحمل اجراءات طالبان
تداعيات عده وتبقى المعركه مع المراه
مفتوحه على مزيد من التصعيد في ظل اسرار
الحركه على قراراتها وغياب ضغوط قادره على
احراز اختراق يذكر العربيه
حظك فرنسا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي على اجراء
اختبارات للمسافرين الصينيين للكشف عن
فيروس كورونا بعد ما قررت باريس اجراءها
في ظل التفشل واسع للجائحه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تسببت عاصفه قويه في هطول امطار غزيره في
معظمها حي ولايه كاليفورنيا الى ازدحام
حركه المرور واغلاق الطرق السريعه وتسبب
انهيار في حدوث فيضانات هائله بالقرب من
ويلتون في الولايه
في نهايه النشره هذا التذكيرهم يا عبد
العزيز العناوي
هجوم اسرائيلي يشل مطار دمشق ويستهدف
مواقع ميليشيات حزب الله جنوب العاصمه
السوريه
وسيارات الروسيه تستهدف كيابا وشرقي
اوكرانيا والجيش الاوكرانيا يرد بقصف
مناطق في بلغراد الروسيه
النظام الايراني يوصلوا اصدار احكام
الاعدام بحق المحتجين والمانيا بجمع
معلومات عن المعارضين على اراضيها
شكرا لكم على طيب المتابعه القاكم بعد
دقائق قليله
[موسيقى]